welcome back everybody and Google
developers live we're on the Udacity
office our show about Quran mobile web
development CS 256 i'm here with Sean
Bennett course architect from Udacity
chris wilson course instructor and
developer advocate at Google and myself
program manager in the google chrome
developer relations scene so we didn't
get a lot of questions this week but
we're talking today specifically about
the responsive images and performance
but Indian I mean you may as well ask
any questions at this point yes both
we're here to answer them anyway and I
think we can make that the same for the
next the following two sessions yeah if
you have questions about other parts of
the course don't feel like you can't ask
them on the forum we have the Dory set
up so if you go to developers that
google.com / live / chrome then you'll
find all of the upcoming episodes there
and you can ask questions into the Dory
at the bottom of those pages so let's
dive into it Beatrice from Munich who's
asking what happens with the problem set
submissions Sean they're marked as done
after you get congrats physically asking
yeah yeah what's up and I show you yeah
thanks Chris it looks like they're there
must be a bug when we kind of migrated
to a new site framework recently I don't
know if you've noticed that change in
look and feel and everything and it's
something I didn't know like it got it
didn't quite get working so i'm gonna
talk to the engineers about that to see
what well we can do to fix it good we
can maybe post mm-hmm reply in the in
the dory yep ok good so we're on it
batteries sorry sean is on a happy
chris is not that and speaking of
frameworks even though to class doesn't
cover frameworks says Sarah in Colorado
Sarah got the floor because she
literally just five minutes ago asked
these questions yeah great the
opportunity to ask your questions right
now it's still live so even though the
class doesn't cover frameworks does
using a framework such as bootstrap or
foundation tend to increase or decrease
performance I think you know before the
show we were talking and we thought
maybe we could each answer at all at
once because I'm pretty sure we have at
least three different yeah things by the
fact that there are two options no no
I'm 30 easy out-of-the-box thinker okay
yeah I think the short answer such as it
is it really depends how carefully you
use the framework it's certainly I think
if you look at bootstrap or foundation
or angular any of the frameworks out
there you know the people who write
these are not slouches and programming
they know what they're doing and they do
write very efficiently in general at the
same time it's definitely possible to
use frameworks in a very inefficient way
certainly I think we got into that
pattern with jquery for a long time but
a lot of developers would leap arm
programming in JavaScript and they would
you know the first thing they would do
is include jquery and then everything
was dollar sign something dollar sign
something like the same thing over and
over and over again and not the most
efficient way to now write code so I
think if you're going to if you're
really interested in performance which I
think we all should be you should very
carefully look at how the framework is
intending you to work and make sure that
you're doing that and then I think
you'll find it probably you know it's it
it's kind of rude to say it increases
performance because that it presumed you
would write very bad code otherwise i
would hope not but I think that it
certainly is not going to be a
you know cause performance degradation
to use a framework yeah good point now
that was a good answer yeah all right
well we have an answer yeah not all at
once yeah you know intelligent use I
think attends to at least at least keep
performance as good as you could make it
mm-hmm well also to see like how many
pieces you need from it yeah absolutely
and that can be a big a big problem is
if you take a big framework yeah and
you're pulling the whole thing down like
people who literally you know I kind of
got away from using jquery and then
finally I thought it through it's like
they're only that I ever want jquery for
is I like that you know dollar sign
rather than having to type out every
time you know right document dot get
element by ID and you know if I aliased
that i was done i just had to be very
intelligent about how i used many ways
yeah joseph and a lot of frameworks have
kind of like a lite version exactly news
like jquery light has i think that and
what they're they're bent syntax and
that's about it and those are generally
the pieces that i want yes i think to
with javascript loaders it's less of a
problem than it used to be but still
something to keep in mind and attention
to yeah and using the proper
minification yeah all of that mean
obviously don't know why as well be
loading all of these resources
separately and typical stuff that you
already probably know how to do yeah
cool all right so next question from
young way in new york from the chrome
dev tools there's a safe to har for all
in the context menu is there any command
line option to automate this so i
actually did a little bit looking into
this i asked the le agregue rick and i
posted a couple of links in the answer
already young way one of the things is
we actually did a show on google
developers live about a year ago i was
called the harsh show with with our
heart I totally want together yes and
called the heart is nothing you can't
resist so allegra gorrik make the
fast he did this show I posted a link to
it and it put a bunch of resources in
there I checked with him he didn't know
about an option to run it from the
command line but posted a few links
there that hopefully might help you out
so there you go next question from Sarah
again is there an overall checklist of
sorts that can be followed to ensure or
evaluate performance throughout the
project I think a great coach it is the
greatness first the first thing I mean
that there are there things that you can
do yeah there are things that you can do
for example page speed mm-hmm so if
you're looking at performance yeah page
speed is a great tool to run your apps
through and get you get a score right so
you can install that you get a score see
exactly the the things that are coming
out bad and then as a instructions how
to fix it there's also there's pretty
new PageSpeed insights that basically
tells you how mobile ready your projects
are definitely check those two out I
think those would be my first yeah yeah
I think actually is is an incredible
evaluator to- as you go along i think
you know a checklist to ensure
performance as you go down yeah right
it's harder so high level that it's its
directive and not really a checklist or
there'd be so many things on it yeah
well and those things are going to
constantly changing too I mean as rue
browsers change and depending on what
browsers target it's it's it's hard to
have like a single checklist that you
can go through I mean I correct me if
I'm wrong but I think the the perf
matters people would probably say use
tools yeah um unfortunately that's that
there's no hard and fast rule but I
think PageSpeed PageSpeed inside can get
so good lately they're really good tools
to use and they're updated often enough
that as things change that Cedric
definite
very good yeah we're putting a lot of
effort behind these are not stale links
that you go to these are like very
actively being developed mhm and and to
I mean it's definitely important to
simply run the devtools all the time
profile your code all the time and
understand where your performance is
going what's taking you know what's
taking your your time what's what's
worth optimizing yeah absolutely yes and
you know not to make it sound vain or
something but the course lesson on
performance we really laid it out we put
the structure in place to kind of cover
the most important bits at these things
that are true across the sword I mean
it's not a checklist yeah following the
high-level topics there and it gets you
an idea yeah yeah I think Colt even
specifically says follow the memory
always follow the memory and that's
that's a great like high level concept
to keep in mind when you're dealing with
performance perf matters alright so the
next question from Craig in Maine what's
the best practice for text sizes and
percents pixel go for so I think you'll
find that percent at the top level
percent is the most flexible meaning
it's going to change on you the most if
you set your text size in percent on the
body and it's just coming from you know
in its inherited size you will find odd
effects happen sometimes like you know I
think I mentioned this during the course
on an iPad if you don't set the initial
scale and you rotate then the text size
actually changes the size doesn't change
but the text size does it's really kind
of bizarre other than that I think that
ms are sort of the same thing they're
off of the inherited sighs so they're
there they're going to change if your
inherited size changes
I'm going to go out on a limb and say
you know pixels are not actually so bad
anymore because they're not really pizza
there there this weird at least two
layers deep of deep of abstraction from
an actual pixel and that means they're
just this arbitrary unit that's kind of
about a 96 DPI pixel held at arm's
length size and it's just a convenient
unit but it's not necessarily exactly a
fun pixel it's probably an alias you
know integer multiple of a pixel but
that's a the best you're going to get
usually in text sizes I tend to think in
points anyway so I frequently will use
points or I'll use pixels if I'm trying
to line up next to an image or something
like that that I want to be in a
multiple yeah there's not a don't do
this because it's horrendously bad other
than understanding that ends or percents
if you use them from the top they're
going to change the best thing probably
to do is define the top level yourself
in a fixed unit and then use em to
present to scale from them know you know
the book from Ethan Marcotte there's a
great chapter about well and it's also
good to look at best practices around
like reset style sheets and raising them
back to you yeah right time we fix the
size of everything right that's probably
where you're going to get the best
students we have it yeah perfect alright
so we have another framework related
question I'm Alper if the objective is
to create a mobile app to be packaged
with phonegap how would your
recommendations change from what we just
discussed for example zooming in and out
may not be relevant in a mobile app
good question you attitude and first of
all let me say don't you don't need to
apologize for asking another framework
all right whatever questions you have
please ask all questions yeah to be
really clear we're not anti framework
should never use frameworks this horse
was really intended to try to ground
developers in what was happening
underneath the framework layer so you
can understand how to use it exactly you
Xandra and what the frameworks doing
yeah i think you know zooming in and out
being relevant on a mobile app it's
really it's true that you get a
different user experience from the top
level using phonegap or another
packaging mechanism but that doesn't
really mean that most of these
recommendations change in any drastic
way certainly if you're writing
something that's going to be full screen
there's no address bar there's no
question of it you know not having
owning all of the space you you may
actually be able to say you know what
I'm going to disable zooming there are
certainly a lot of scenarios where it's
okay to say no I don't want the user to
be able to scale this as long as you
take into account things like you know
if they really can't read my tiny little
text that's sort of a problem so in
general I don't think I'm trying to
think through everything we said in the
course which is obviously quite a lot I
can't think of anything which doesn't
apply yeah I mean inside a and most of
it i would say still applies quite well
I mean phonegap really doesn't mitigate
understanding of basic web development
practices no with a room and a lot of
what we say is it's built on just you
know extending that to mobile yeah right
that's all yes in short so ello in
Colorado what other course can I take to
improve on mobile web development we're
in this part 2 coming out yeah so I
think that part of the point with making
this courses that there weren't a whole
lot of good resources that you were just
like a course that we're all packaged
together in something that you can
understand all in one place so one
answer that might be there there isn't
any right now unfortunately having said
that I heard you're doing more courses
though and i am sure that's one of the
5858 soaring about that yeah yeah we're
just gonna leave that's not only one of
the fish definitely something we want to
get a jump on but yeah I mean we don't
have anything right now I mean I mean
there are a lot of resources that you
can that you can look at that you know
are kind of scattered all over the place
not not so much like a single course we
if you take a look in the materials and
the wiki section of the course then
we've got a whole list of links to
external resources html5 rocks articles
right gdl sessions I think we've got
some html5 dev com I mean up in there I
would say though that even though it's
not specific to mobile there are some
great mobile web development or sources
cs2 50 52 53 some of the concepts there
of course easily yeah come over to a
mobile web development especially some
of the backend stuff doesn't change at
all yeah I mean in 255 it kind of
introduces the ground cept of a sprite
sheet which is something you're seeing
more and more people use anything lies
images anything that Cole talks about
will be applicable to mobile because
well it's so much over Florence don't
let him hear you
none of us perf matters yeah so
hopefully we'll be building more yeah
the other thing that I will say too is
there's no no replacement for experience
and what you should really do is pick
some projects you wanna play around with
and build them as mobile web apps then
after you've done this a few times yeah
go back and review the lessons thing in
this course and think through how these
apply now that you've got some
experience and I think that will that's
going to help you improve more anything
I certainly I improve more about doing
than guy absolutely yeah and I mean 11
really useful thing is while you're
making these these apps while you're
building these projects you know just
keep a keep a running tally of where are
the pain points are the things that I
didn't expect you know just keep a check
to keep a checklist or something of
things to watch out for you know build
your own checklist of things that you've
had problems with in the past and you
need to remember yeah or if there's
something that seems like I completely
don't understand this part like why do I
care about you know how often I ping the
network or something write that down and
come back to it later yeah you know
played around them yeah see much getting
in the next stuff so we're asking the
next I hope this absolutely cool well we
already down to the last question from
ello and Colorado it yes unless we get
some more unless they come in yes that's
right we've said that before so is there
a free alternative to impact j/s
I hacked yes yeah I do yeah so impact
j/s as a game engine right it's
fantastic game engine yes it's a
fantastic game engine mm-hmm I don't
know if there's like a head-to-head
comparison two things I would point you
to one my favorite graphics engine is
three Jas yeah so i have to mention that
html5 game engine com actually is a nice
comparison chart I have different game
engines what their licensing is and then
sort of things so you might start their
html5 game engine com yeah yeah and
depending on if you need a full game
engine or just smaller pieces of one you
might look at other things as well I'm
box2d is fantastic yeah right now I
really awesome seaport excellent all
right so wrong with that I think we're
down to the last question or that was
the last question you'll see ya what I'm
not saying one so um well again we'll be
back next week same time actually Chris
will be on a beach in Maui some details
it's a rough life so it'll just be Shawn
in myself okay here in the studio so ask
your questions about the next lessons
eight and nine but if you have questions
about any of the other lessons feel free
to ask those as well or mobile web dev
in general yeah sure sure any of the
questions you have these GDL shows
they're recorded their live and as soon
as they're done they're available in
recorded form at the same URL on
developers.google.com / lives so with us
thanks Chris Sean and see you next week
yeah thanks Pierre see you guys